let me get to the uh north carolina head
coach uh mac brown who uh
is you're about the same age as coach
saban aren't you mac
uh dan i'll be 69 at the end of this
month so yes
all right i like that do you have an
email address
what i do is i'm not near as smart as
nick i answer my own emails and he's got
somebody else answering here
so what a great thing if you say i don't
text
i don't answer the phone i don't have a
cell phone i don't have an email
uh so don't contact me
i think that's it i may go to all that
today i may cancel my email after the
show
you got uh syracuse on september 12th at
home
how confident are you that you're going
to play that game
dan i think we're going to play and my
job is to lead this team
so i've got to um
everything i do is to prepare to play
what our presidents have said and i'm
very proud of their their stance
and they've talked to our medical
experts is that they haven't said we're
going to play
they've said that we're moving forward
trying to make sure that it's safe
enough to play
and i think that's good we have not had
uh positives on the football field we've
practiced now probably 11 times and it's
good and
kids are staying safe where all of us
have issues is when they leave our
football area the complex and and they
they have their
normal social lives and things have
changed they can't have that normal
social life anymore
and also if the students are on campus
but not going to classes
i would think that that helps your
football team staying safe
you know and not being out in the you
know the general population there that
you can almost
keep them in a bubble of sorts on campus
is that the game plan
dan it is uh basketball's proven that
that works and
uh even when we were going to class the
last week
the classes were very safe somebody was
holding the door there were
probably a third of the normal people in
the classroom the normal students they
were social distance
they all had mass so our players told me
they felt very comfortable
i think again dan our problem is is when
you get outside of
football outside of the classroom and
kids are going to be kids and and we're
we're all telling them where i'm asked
if you'll do that in social distance be
around people that are wearing a mask
wash your hands sanitize everything the
universities are trying to do everything
in their power to help
and now we've got to have the students
to step up and help us as well
why is it the acc big 12 and sec are
still trying to play planning on playing
and the pac-12 in big ten or not
it seems to me it's just the difference
in medical opinions
the medical experts seem to think it's
not as safe for the the big ten and the
pac-12 and
the medical experts here and and the
triangle is one of the top medical
centers in the world
uh we have great medical experts and and
they've done everything
that we do dan they've touched it
they're talking about how many fans can
be in the stands where they said how we
eat how we
have our team meetings they they have
looked at and approved everything
and as long as these brilliant people
think that it's safe for these young
people to play
the kids want to play the coachees want
to play we had our best practice
yesterday and i wish that our fans and
media could be out there to watch
they're excited and they're having fun
and it's probably one of the few normal
things right now in their lives
me coach have you heard from players uh
parents through this
yes we've we've tried to keep in
constant contact with the parents
and uh well even on monday night dan we
had uh
i opened the meeting we had a zoom
meeting with all of our parents
and we had our doctors on there we had
our trainers on there
and and they gave them a presentation of
how things are going and what we're
doing and why we're doing it
and then had an hour available for uh
for questions so i think you've got to
over communicate it at this time and
we've told our players and probably to
nauseam that
if you don't feel comfortable if you
don't want to play don't practice today
and
it's not the best to get ready for
syracuse but these times are different
and we have to handle these
times differently and if you want to opt
out if you don't feel comfortable you
don't want to play you get to keep your
scholarship
but come back and see us in january or
when this
this virus goes away yeah and you know
it's
it's really tricky because you can do
everything right the
athletic director the school the players
but it comes down to the student body as
well
like you these players have got to be
diligent in policing themselves and
that's hard to do coach when you're 20
21
22 years of age on a college campus well
it is dan you and i don't like wearing
the mask
you you're a very personable guy you
don't like staying away from people that
are friends of yours and
i can't shake a hand i can't hug
somebody's neck and and all that's
different now than it's ever been in our
lives before
uh and what we've got to do is show
great leadership for these young people
and by doing that then they've got to
follow us and
and i think the other thing is that it's
never been more important
to have a team-led team than uh right
now
that when when they're away from us
we've told them if you want to play
then use social distance you wear your
mask if you don't care
then that's okay but if you want to play
you've got to do what the medical
experts are telling you to do
because that's going to be the
difference when it comes down to when
they make a final decision
any chance you keep notre dame for good
in the acc with football
but i would love that it it'd be a win
for
the acc great program obviously
a tremendous brand nationally
great tv revenue and market uh
they do it right they go by the rules
they're always going to be good
uh so it would be a home run for us if
we could what do you have uh
in your office there that the coolest
thing you have in the office there
there's what
uh the national championship trophy
that's right over my shoulder that i'm
hoping every recruit sees
[Laughter]
you should walk around with that you
know just like a push cart
you know a scooter or something and have
that you go back to that 2005
season the play that vince young ran
what was the call and was was that a
designed play to beat usc
it was a design play it was menu number
two
because at that time we were going no
huddle because it was the end of the
game and
and uh you you had to get the
play in very quickly and i'll never
forget it was a play that vince told us
he wanted to run if we got in that
situation because we said what's your
your best go to play if we get down to
the end and we have to make a play and
he said menu two and and so we called it
and i'll never forget that i said look
quickly
and if they're open throw it but if not
your legs are pretty darn good for
five yards so uh don't be hesitant to
pull it down and run it
and uh he wasn't throwing it coach no
no he pulled the old i'm gonna fake it
like i'm gonna throw it
and then got that end zone very quickly
why didn't he work out in the nfl do you
know in in some ways he did
dan he was uh rookie of the year and
made the pro bowl a couple of times and
he helped the
the titans get to the playoffs i worry
sometimes that young people that leave a
year early
maybe aren't quite as ready for all the
stuff
as much as they are the football and it
was a very uncomfortable situation too
that uh
coach fisher didn't want him norm chow
they both wanted matt leinart who is a
great player
but norm had coach matt at usc and
but adams the owner wanted vince because
he was from houston
so they were kind of forced into taking
him and then
when they said we want matt leinart and
then you're forced to take somebody else
they came to me and said how are we
gonna handle this and i said it's not
good brother
you better go talk to vince very quickly
and tell him that
the reason it wasn't that you didn't
want vince you wanted matt
because he ran your system and and you
were very comfortable with him so
it just didn't start out right and i
don't think it was ever really good
has michael jordan been to a practice he
has not i've seen him in town a couple
of times and michael's very supportive
and of course we all love the last dance
and
uh he is so competitive when i saw him
last spring
in jordan brand his shoes dan he's got
michigan
he's got oklahoma he's got florida and
he's got north carolina
so here i am the new coach and i said
michael why did you give your shoe
brand to to oklahoma and to michigan and
florida man
why didn't you just give them to us and
he said why don't you start winning some
games
like the rest of them and then we'll
talk about it
and i thought yeah that's fair yeah
you became now you know what his
teammates felt like when he was there
pro questions what they did i said yes
sir
uh good luck and uh trying to pull this
off coach it's great to talk to you you
got syracuse september 12th
in chapel hill uh great to see you hope
you're well thank you
thanks dan i appreciate you thanks for
having me on you keep yourself
safe and healthy thank you coach that's
uh mac brown